pourquoi est-ce que depuis que je suis
tout petit je suis tant attiré par la
différence que j'en suis venu à faire le
tour du monde
je n'ai dans le 15e arrondissement de
paris un arrondissement qui est plutôt
bourgeois qui est pas loin d'ici en tout
cas majoritairement blancs et pourtant
mes parents ont fait le choix de masse
que la risée dans une école primaire
vous sur 200 élèves y avait 42
nationalités
s'est donc rendu dans un espèce de
melting-pot comme ça où il y avait cette
religion pratiquée dans le cadre de
l'école des dizaines de culture des
centaines d'origine et puis je me suis
nous et d'amitié avec quelques amis avec
4 en particulier on a monté un petit
groupe d'amis qui s'appelait club des
cinq
et puis j'ai réalisé que ses amis l'a en
fait été interne il dormait dans l'école
moi j'étais externe et puis un soir je
demande à mes parents mais pourquoi
est-ce que antoine pascal fabrice
grégoire tout le monde dit ils dorment
dans l'école alors que moi je rentre le
soir mes parents m'explique que la
plupart des élèves de l'école plus de la
moitié soit parce qu'ils étaient enfants
de diplomates soit parce qu'ils avaient
été confisqués à leurs parents par la
das pour viol violences
vivait dans l'école toute la semaine
alors je leur demande s'il était
possible
de les faire sortir dès l'école parfois
pour qu'ils puissent eux aussi voir
paris que moi j'avais l'habitude de le
faire le soir le mercredi après midi le
samedi et mes parents acceptent de se
porter garant alors un mercredi par mois
la directrice signent une décharge et
les quatre amis du club des cinq sortes
avec moi dans paris
quelques années plus tard je rentre au
collège beaucoup plus près d'ici juste à
côté du luxembourg
dans un établissement qui n'avait plus
rien à voir et sur deux mille élèves ils
avaient tous la même tête que moi il
était blanc et une tête de kato
je découvre cet établissement petit à
petit et je commence à sentir sans m'en
rendre compte au début que quelque chose
me manque il ya un élément dans mon
entourage qui fait que je ressens que
j'ai besoin de cette diversité que je
n'ai plus que j'avais quand j'étais à
l'école primaire et donc je suis
demandeur justement de cette altérité
qui a totalement disparu de mon
entourage l'établissement est tellement
homogène que chaque année l'épreuve
d'éducation civique nous font faire un
vote fictifs sur les opinions politiques
et chaque année ça donne 80 % de vote à
droite ou à l'extrême droite
l'établissement est tellement homogène
que quand en seconde il ya deux arabes
qui rentre dans l'établissement par la
discrimination positive tout le monde
les a remarqués
alors je me dis c'est pas suffisant il
faut que je retrouve quelque chose pour
me remettre en lien avec ce besoin
profond ce désir qui est d'être au
contact de l'autre en rentrant en
seconde la prof nous dit cet été au mois
de juin vous aurez un mois de stage a
assuré dans une association
anticipé de choisir votre association
alors je cherche dans mon entourage et
puis j'entends dans les médias qu'on
parlait d'argenteuil à cette époque
argenteuil était tristement connue parce
qu' il fallait passer à argenteuil au
kärcher alors je me dis allons voir
argenteuil et trouvons un stage là-bas
je suis embauché comme stagiaire
j'arrive à argenteuil sauf qu'entre
temps on l'établissement scolaire avait
un peu t pain sur moi donc j'arrive sur
cette fameuse dalle d'argenteuil avec la
chemise boutonnée jusqu'au dernier étage
le pantalon les mocassins et la ceinture
au dessus du nombril
les camarades que j'ai rencontré là bas
m'ont fait le cadeau de leur
bienveillance et de leur tolérance en
quelque sorte ils m'ont accueilli comme
j'étais et je veux j'ai senti sur place
un tel abaissement que je me suis dit
vraiment pas besoin de ça il faut que tu
arrives à te remettre en contact avec de
l'hétérogénéité avec de l'altérité avec
de la différence alors en 2007 une année
plus tard après ce stage c'est le
centenaire du scoutisme est donc mon
groupe scout qui lui était catholique
décide d'aller à james ford en
angleterre pour fêter son centième
anniversaire
et là il faut arriver à chelmsford je
fais une découverte extraordinaire les
scouts ne sont pas catholiques et
figurez-vous même que la majorité les
scouts dans le monde comme à ce
rassemblement sont musulmans puisque
dans le monde il ya plus de scouts
musulmans que de scouts chrétiens et sur
cette esplanade de 50000 scouts réunis
pour l'anniversaire du scoutisme on a
neuf rennes religion qui sont pratiqués
sur place évidemment ça me rappelle
l'école dans laquelle j'ai grandi on a
des dizaines de culture on à 192 nations
et je me souviens que je suis très
touché par cette capacité que le
scoutisme à
deux mètres près aux deux marqueurs le
marqueur de l'unité est le marqueur de
la diversité mark hurd unités parce
qu'évidemment quand on écoute sur la
même esplanade là tous une chemise de
boy scouts avec le foulard le salut
scouts les valeurs le fondateur mais en
même temps beaucoup de marqueurs de
diversité parce que les foulards sont
jamais les mêmes la couleur de la
chemise et le change ça fait un peu
comme des smarties dans un prix
les cultures ne sont pas les mêmes les
religions les couleurs de peau et donc
je le vis concrètement sur place comment
est ce qu'il était possible de vivre
justement cette unité cette diversité
un troisième moment dans ma vie va
marquer un tournant
dans cette quête cette volonté de faire
quelque chose pour faire advenir une
société qui ressemble à mon école
primaire
à la fin de la première on part en
voyage à auschwitz
en train
28 heures de train dans un sens 28
heures de train dans l'autre trois jours
sur place entrée auschwitz birkenau
immuno vite
dans le silence la pauvreté l'humilité
et sur le trajet du retour je me vois
encore en train d'écrire dans mes notes
sur les 28 heures de train entre la
ville d'oswiecim qui est en pologne et
paris et je me vois écrire commune à
quelque chose depuis que tu es né qui te
me qui te bouffe qui te fait lever le
matin c'est que tu va toujours chercher
des personnes différentes de toi tu as
besoin de vivre dans un environnement
plurielle et auschwitz c'est la victoire
du contraire
auschwitz est la résultante de la haine
de l'autre de l'anéantissement de la
diversité de la destruction du
pluralisme auschwitz c'est exactement
tout le contraire de ce pour quoi toi tu
veux contribuer dans ce monde alors
maintenant du haut de ses 16 ans quand
tu rentres à paris il faut que tu fasses
quelque chose qui permette de construire
pour empêcher une victoire totale de
suite sur l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est trouver c'est un peu une un hasard
je sais pas si c'est un heureux hasard
ou un triste hasard mais à cette époque
on est en janvier 2009 le conflit
israélo palestinien en france
en israël palestine pardon fait rage en
france puisqu'il est importé comme
souvent par les communautés qui
revendique telle ou telle prise de
position alors comme à chaque fois il ya
des manifestations pro juif pro
palestinienne on l'a relativement
l'habitude sauf que en ce jour mois de
janvier 2009 un drame arrive gare du
nord deux cortèges se croisent et
s'affronter font des victimes
j'ai trouvé ça tellement absurde que je
me suis dit est ce que quelque chose en
france existe aujourd'hui pour qu'on
puisse manifester notre désaccord avec
cette importation d'un an et demi en
france alors on peut avoir son opinion
sur un conflit sur une population mais
de là à désigner sur place l'ennemi qui
est dans notre propre pays alors il ya
eu cette journée incroyable 14 janvier
je me souviens tous les médias français
les quotidiens et puis toutes les
communautés religieuses décide journée
blanche aujourd'hui partout dans tous
les théâtres de france peut-être à
bobino en tout cas moi je me souviens au
théâtre de la place duplex organisons
des manifestations où tous les français
seront rassemblés juif chrétien musulman
athée pour dire non à l'importation de
ce conflit et oui à une construction
commune d'une société je me rends à la
manifestation la plus proche de chez moi
il y avait 600 personnes dans le théâtre
je crois un peu comme ce soir j'étais au
premier rang aussi comme ce soit
et le speaker qui dirigeait la
manifestation se rend compte qu'ils
avaient un petit jeune là qui avait 16
piges et me demande de venir sur scène
pour expliquer la motivation à cette
réunion je n'ai pas du tout préparé je
m'attendais pas donc je viens côté de
lui je prend le micro et je sais pas
pourquoi quelque chose m'est venu à
l'esprit jeudi à toute la salle
vous croyez pas qu'il ya trop de sang
qui a coulé pour la guerre si on faisait
couler le sang pour la paix
les gens m'ont gardé comme ça faire
couler le sang pour la paix qu'est ce
qui veut dire et je reconnais quelques
visages de jeunes dans la salle et je
leur dis s'il ya des jeunes ici est-ce
que vous accepteriez de me rejoindre
pour qu'on organise ensemble un don du
sang et qu'on montre que au delà de nos
différences de religion et de conviction
on peut faire quelque chose de concret
ensemble
alors on a organisé cette journée don du
sang on s'est réunis tous
de toutes les religions on a décidé de
se donner un nom coexister de se donner
un message la co existence active de se
donner un nom de code pour l'opération
c'était ensemble à 100% et on organise
cette initiative six ans plus tard on
est plus 11 on et 2000 il ya plus un
groupe à paris il y en a 30 dans toute
la france il ya plus que des bénévoles
il ya sept salariés il n'y a plus que
des volontaires il ya des volontaires en
service civique une trentaine et le
mouvement a pris de l'ampleur et donc
j'ai pu qu en quelque sorte réaliser le
petit rêve que j'avais l'école primaire
qui était de construire une société qui
ressemble un peu à ce qu'on m'avait
appris dans la plus petite enfance et
pourtant ça n'a pas suffi je me suis dit
on a un corps qui aime beaucoup de
problèmes sur le sujet en france je
pense que tout le monde est d'accord ici
on en parle beaucoup souvent de façon
négative la diversité de religion de nos
religions est souvent vu comme un
problème il faudrait qu'on aille voir
ailleurs comment ça se passe alors je me
suis dit on va faire une méthode
radicale on va prendre un peu un bocal
ou un loft story on va mettre un juif un
chrétien un musulman en alternance dans
un avion c'est pas une blague et on va
partir tous les cinq fait le tour du
monde
alors on commence le voyage tous les
cinq avec chacun notre rôle un peu dans
le casting mais aussi toute notre
histoire et on part chercher dans 70
villes dans 40 pays des initiatives qui
donne des idées pour un modèle de
société qui respecte le pluralisme la
diversité de religion le voyage se passe
bien on passe deux mois en europe un
mois au moyen-orient est petit on arrive
en afrique jusque là évidemment on vous
imaginez faire un tour du monde quand on
a 22 ans et forcément une très grande
joie et puis on arrivait en inde tout
change
en arrivant en inde et en commençant
trois mois de parcours en asie entre
l'inde et l'indonésie
sur 11 pays et quelque chose à
l'intérieur qui a pété ait eu un gros
bug
j'avais envie de rentrer j'étais pas
bien là où j'étais j'avais peur et
j'étais terrorisée de ce continent je
découvrais l'un de plein fouet d'abord
pour la pauvreté mais aussi parce que la
vision du monde qu'on les indiens les
hindous les musulmans
surtout les hindous n'a rien à voir avec
la vision du monde qu'on a en occident
l'afrique ou l'amérique ici la ville y
en a qu'une elle est linéaire donc on a
une naissance on vit cette vie on meurt
et puis c'est terminé en inde une
sauvegarde quand vous mourrez vous avez
une réincarnation derrière le rapport à
la ville est forcément complètement
différent et donc l'acceptation aussi
des castes et de la pauvreté est
forcément différent le tel choc culturel
que je me suis pris dans la figure m'a
fait dire mais ça fait quand même six
ans que tu travailles sur cette question
que tu fréquentes énormément de religion
de convictions différentes que à 16 ans
quand un imam est venu de chercher à la
sortie de la messe pour te dire tu
voudrais venir prendre un pot chez nous
thiel et pour rencontrer justement les
musulmans de ton quartier tu sais ce que
c'est que la différence et pourtant
j'étais pas bien et pourtant j'avais
peur
le tour du monde a terminé et j'ai mis
beaucoup de temps à comprendre pourquoi
est-ce que l'asie était si douloureuse
pour moi pourquoi est ce que en asie
j'ai eu si peur de tout peur de la vie
peur de la mort peur du sens peur de
peur de ce voyage même de mon engagement
est en fête avec le recul j'ai compris
quelque chose
la 6è l'altérité maximale c'est le trop
plein de différence et c'est presque le
choc de de tout ce qui est plus nouveau
et de et de contraire à ce qu'on vit
dans notre pays d'origine et en fait
j'ai compris que mon intuition d'origine
elle était bonne mais je n'avais pas
assez creusé
l'intuition d'origine qu'on avait avec
coexister c'était que pour permettre à
des jeunes différentes vivre ensemble il
faut réconcilier les paradoxes par
exemple que la même chose créer de
l'identité et de l'altérité comment
c'est possible ça en asie je me suis
pris énormément d'altérité dans la
figure
et j'étais loin en fait de chez moi
quand on travaille en france dans un
pays qui est le nôtre avec notre
histoire avec notre enracinement c'est
facile de s'ouvrir mais quand on est
loin de son histoire de sa famille de
ses habitudes alimentaires de la planche
de saucisson dans le café d'en bas
forcément de l'altérité l'est beaucoup
plus difficile à digérer alors j'ai
compris à ce moment là que pour vraiment
s'ouvrir à l'autre on avait besoin
justement de réconcilier plein de
paradoxes et que l'identité et
l'altérité c'était un peu comme
déracinés des branches et qu'aucun arbre
n'est capable d'ouvrir ses branches
justement à un monde différent s'il
n'est pas lui-même très enracinée et ça
marche pour d'autres choses ça marche
pour l'unité et la diversité vous n'avez
pas remarqué dans le discours médiatique
on dit toujours par rapport à la
différence malgré la différence à cause
de la différence en dépit de la
différence comme c'est la différence
était toujours négative pourquoi on peut
pas dire le contraire grâce à la
différence et donc du coup se dire qu'on
crée quelque chose qui va à la fois
favoriser la ressemblance est la
différence
sa gelée compris en particulier grâce à
mes quatre camarades et je leur rends
hommage jocelyn victor ismaël et ilan
qui ont vécu pendant un an avec moi dans
ces 40 pays et depuis que je suis rentré
en france j'ai compris que pour
permettre un véritable équilibre et une
véritable harmonie entre des personnes
qui sont profondément différente il
fallait apprendre à gérer ses paradoxes
entre l'identité et l'altérité
l'unité et la diversité la ressemblance
est la différence le commun et le
singulier les racines et les branches
merci